september starts tomorrow which means
there are new watering groups all across
the valley you've got to pay attention
to this groups are no longer designated
by zip codes and this is an attempt to
just make it easier for residents to
conserve water
candace charles joining us live from the
newsroom to talk about the impact
candace that's going to hit us in the
wallet if we don't abide by these
watering rules that is absolutely right
heather good morning to you guys good
morning folks on thursday it's the start
of the fall watering schedule customers
will go from a five-day watering
schedule to a three-day what is new is
who can water when take a look at this
map according to this map only three of
the six watering groups will be allowed
to water on thursday when those new
watering groups take effect the change
as i mentioned coincides with the
beginning of the mandatory fall watering
schedule that was the schedule there as
we continue to see the drought's impact
on lake mead a crucial water source for
25 million people city officials across
the state are implementing water
restrictions including drought tolerant
landscaping in january southern nevada's
water allocation was reduced by 7
billion gallons enough water to serve 45
000 homes city officials say when it
comes to abiding by restrictions every
little drop helps
it is critically important to abide by
the water groups remember these are
mandatory watering groups that are being
implemented not just by us but all
across the region
there are fines that can potentially be
levied uh most of our residents are on
smart meters so you can track your water
usage
yes we're talking about money so you
want to listen up here take a look at
that map of the new wiring groups and
the schedule once more
watering days other than assigned
watering days during restricted hours or
other wasteful water could result in a
fine of eighty to more than five
thousand dollars depending on the amount
of water and number of violations and
you can take a look at that breakdown
map and schedule on our website eight
newsnow dot com